California suspends Cru Robo taxis after
car dragged pedestrian 20 ft horrifying
hit and run triggers California
suspension of Cru Robo taxis most people
don't know this this is the craziest
thing um we don't really talk about it
that much but uh in San Francisco
they're their taxi with no
drivers right did you guys were you guys
you guys know that it's been it's been
some time and it's just never been big
news that oh yeah that thing yeah well
it happened cars are driving themselves
and the car will pull up you'll get in
and it'll drive you to destination
there's nobody there well this car ran
somebody over dragged them and kept them
pinned as they screamed for mercy and
help and the car didn't care cuz it
can't they say Less Than 3 months after
the California Public Utilities
Commission approved Robo taxi service
cruises plan to provide Around the Clock
driverless riders in San Francisco the
California Department of Motor Vehicles
has shut down Cruz's driverless
operations the suspension followed two
notable accidents involving Cruz's Robo
taxis in August one person was injured
after a cruise vehicle crashed into a
fir Tru and earlier this month a
pedestrian using a crosswalk was found
in critical condition after a driver of
another vehicle struck The Pedestrian
and threw her into the path of an
oncoming Cruise Robo taxi the hidden run
incident is still being investigated
according to cruise its autonomous
vehicle detected the collision and
stopped on top of The Pedestrian then
off the road dragging The Pedestrian 20
ft when the AV finally stopped it
appeared to pin the pedestrian's leg
beneath a tire while videos show the
pedestrians screaming for help wow so
this one uh wow the dystopia is here
guys uh did you know that MGM let me let
me let me check the app real quick did
you know that MGM casinos have been they
were hacked uh and they've oh yes
they've not come back they they they
they've announced like it should much of
it is back to normal M but uh for those
that are familiar if you into playing
poker there's an app called Bravo
there's a couple of them Bravo tracks
the available poker rooms around you
okay as of right now mgm's app is live
once again but for I think like a month
or two it was down their computer
systems got hacked the entire MGM
networks from Vegas to to DC wherever I
don't I don't know where the other
casinos are and um everything was in
cash they somehow they got I think they
got fished someone sent an email they
clicked the link installed they ran
somewhere on on on their computer which
infected the entire network and they
said pay us millions of dollars
otherwise we shut you down they said we
will not pay the entire casino Network
got shut down I would like you to
imagine this scenario MGM does not
operate autonomous machines that weigh a
ton MGM has a bunch of well technically
I guess you could say they do they have
slot machines I don't know if they weigh
a ton but they're not
mobile these Robo taxi companies you are
going to have a fleet of AI automated
driverless cars and what happens when an
employee clicks a link installs
ransomware on their servers and then all
of the of the robo taxis are locked and
can't be altered in any way and they say
we're not paying the ransom and the cars
just start driving around with no human
control or input I suppose I suppose the
argument will be like we can do nothing
to stop the cars they're going to keep
operating as as they do and maybe they
just pick people up and drop them off
but with the ransomware what's to stop
someone from just controlling the
entirety of the fleet with a single
malware link and then making all the
cars I don't know drive into the bay
it's a black Mir episode it's a black
mirr episode honestly this is why I'm
not getting the neural link yeah I mean
honestly oh you don't have a choice well
I'm also going to be om in mandating the
the V Tim is mandating the neuralink
it's a company no I'm just kidding I'm
going to be a reclus in the woods
terrifying terrifying yeah if it can
happen to that the nink I'm against it
but I also I'm like uhoh no no no what
no no no no okay you know what you know
what the the woke leftists are going to
do with neuralink mhm they're so you
know right with neuralink you can if you
could read write capabilities and you
can enter a metaverse where you can
actually experience like a real
alternate reality all of these woke
leftists are going to go into the
metaverse and create white men
avatars yeah their their Marx's Paradise
will be in the metaverse well and I mean
look if you were going to if you were
going to go into a video if you're going
to make a video game and someone said
you can choose between uh these five
different characters you've got the the
the fighter the Barbarian The Bard the
cleric the Monk and if you choose
Barbarian you get double the experience
you get double the HP you get double the
resources double the money everyone
agrees with you and the game's super
easy you'd be like well maybe I want the
challenge but a lot of people are going
to be like look I'll just I'll I'll take
the the the strong guy that his stats
are way better so if the leftist
argument is you know white privilege
they will choose to play as white people
in the metaverse yeah recognize their
privilege in the mete let's put it this
way we're not even I'm not even talking
about a video game with stats or
something right imagine someone is
working in the metaverse jobs are
digital do you think these woke leftists
are going to choose non-white avatars or
do you think they're going to be like
I'm like there's going to be like a
Hispanic woman who super W and she be
like if I if I make a white male Avatar
I'll get hired right well the rules of
intersectionality apply in the metaverse
like but like who's going to legislate
all of it like Congress like they can't
even like get Facebook right you know
good luck I mean so the the self-driven
cars really freak me out for a lot of
reasons I I just I would never want
anyone I love to get in one and I
understand there could be maybe an
argument that they are helpful that they
you know make it so women can stay at
work longer instead of driving their
kids around or whatever thing the
utopian left is trying to sell But
ultimately you know anything controlled
by a computer is subjective to failure
and there's no way to protect against
that I mean humans go Rogue too but I
wonder if the reason they're destroying
San Francisco is to create a a a test
City for all the weird robot crap
they're
doing crap did you did you see the uh
the they have those robot food
delivery and some dude was going around
they were flipping them
destroy and
stealing was it San Francisco who has
the robot dog police or is that another
place in California like food delivery
apparently you can buy those robot dogs
now and they're not that expensive I
mean they're expensive don't get me
wrong but they would you name one what
would you name a robot dog uh Sparky no
it's got to be it's got to be something
like uh endbringer you know here he is
let's bring him in right now Tim's new
robot dog well right because it's like
you know the heral of the end of days
you know I mean me the heral end of of
the end of days call Harold well instead
of Harold you can just use a word that
represents the sound made so I like
haral they had some in La at downtown LA
and like really just like the people did
they just kicked it all over yeah the
delery I'm sorry like the people
smashing the robot food delivery things
I get it it's wrong don't break other
people's stuff but it is kind of
hilarious like I thought it was the
funniest thing ever it's it's so
dystopian these like massive tech
companies that are Ultra woke and and
these horrible policies build these
robots to deliver food to get rid of
Labor and don't be com to Downtown LA
where there's like so many homeless
people this is this is the future it's
like I I watched I watched elesium today
and I was making fun of it you guys ever
see alium I like it it's good I if it's
scary I won't watch it no it's a Sci-Fi
with Matt Damon and Earth is
overpopulated and everyone lives in
squalor and the ultra wealthy live in a
space an orbital space station Paradise
called elium and I'm just like his movie
is such leftist propaganda and it is cuz
like the rich people have a machine that
can cure any disease and the only reason
they don't give it to the poor is cuz
they don't want to that's classic rich
people Behavior they're just like that
right they just don't want to give
people The Cure it's like let them die
and like okay no like the reality is in
the real world it's scarcity but seeing
that and then seeing stuff like this I'm
like you know it's not that far off
where you're going to have 90% of people
are homeless homeless like street urchin
types running around smashing autonomous
food delivery to find food and it's
going to be this weirdest thing where
like the companies that do the food
delivery will have flying drones
delivering food to other wealthy people
who live in the top of towers and when
the homeless 90% Chuck rocks at it to
knock it down to get food the companies
say yeah it's fine though because we
don't have employees we save so much
money the cost of the food absorbs all
of the damages business expense yeah
yeah so when Amazon opened that store
where you didn't have any staff yeah
Amazon go and you could just walk in and
grab whatever you wanted I very easily
which was the weirdest thing have you
ever tried they're all over yes and so
uh I the moment they opened it I
immediately discovered an exploit to be
able to get whatever you want for free
and so we did a test run where we were
able to trick the system into giving me
a massive bag of groceries free of
charge now don't get me wrong we did pay
for everything but uh going into great
details about what we did because
uh uh when I talked to Amazon the
general answer that I got was we don't
care about shoplifting we save so much
money by not having employees right that
shoplifting is negligible to us I find
myself when I go to the grocery store
and there are the self checkout lanes
and then there ones with the employees I
find myself wanting to go to where the
employees are because I just feel like
they're getting deleted even if it's
faster I feel like like there's some
sort of like loyalty to humanity like
another human person with a job I need
you to be there so that you have your
job so we can continue doing this
otherwise it's just like deleting people
all the time heard also part of it is
that companies don't have to deal with
any wastage now they have all those
products that are going to be going bad
whatever they have to deal with that
stuff because people that are like
getting it shoplifted they don't have to
worry about getting or getting rid of
the products after the fact they just
people just take it so it's like they're
like he whatever there's there's more
except now it's like don't have to pay
someone to take it off the shelf to
remove it so again deleting people this
way this is why I say the '90s is the
best just the best it was the last I put
up uh I made a video when we did this
where in one continuous shot I take my
bag of groceries exit walk a block away
set it down pull out all the all of the
food and then wait for the Amazon app to
confirm the purchase and it said I
bought a pack of gum and I had no that
happened to me too I had like a whole
cart it was like in Buffalo Grove when I
was visiting my parents it was the
weirdest thing I I was like so weirded
out that we just walked in and I walked
out and they calculated everything and
it became like it was like $5 because
they didn't calculate properly yeah well
for us we intentionally found a way to
exploit Amazon system okay I didn't we
intentionally made it ring me up for a
pack of gum when I had a full bag of
groceries wow because but they don't
care and so recently at DCA Airport they
now have an Amazon go sensors all along
the ceiling you scan your hand you walk
in take whatever you want and walk out
nice no no no no I'm not doing that scan
hand thing I resisted when the iPhone
like had you put your thumb print in so
you could like open whole button I
didn't like that for the longest time
there I think I can I I would say we
probably found four different exploits
for this system where potentially if you
keep doing it over and over again
they're going to call the police on you
and the cops are going to come be like
this is not an accident you're doing
this on purpose but uh there's probably
four different exploits for getting
whatever you want for free that's crazy
I do not recommend doing it but you got
to ask what their policies are because
apparently like there have been
statements about like they don't care if
people take whatever they want MH like
the argument made is how do you prove it
shoplifting if you tell the people to
take whatever they want and walk
out yeah seriously I don't know I mean
theoretically they have to post I'm
trying to think of like comparing it to
like trespassing or anything else like
you have to post science being like
here's exactly how you pay for it but it
doesn't make any sense I think it's
civil if if you go into a grocery store
and take something and leave with it
that's shoplifting because you're
supposed to stop and pay but if they
tell you don't worry just walk out and
we'll charge you for it trust us hey I
did everything they told me to do if
they didn't charge me that's their fault
I think the same thing with the self
checkout at the grocery store like if
you do it they're always really annoying
and if it doesn't scan but you put it in
your bag and then it keeps going like
are you shoplifting or is their system
just bad but usually they'll say oh it
didn't scan sometimes but sometimes
it'll go away or they'll be like there
was there was some lady who had like a
this is a big story she had like a 90
Cent item that didn't scan and so they
called the cops on the cops came in
rested her and and the video like this
is old story apparently the video showed
that she did run everything over the
scanner and then this one small item
didn't scan but she didn't notice and
they were like oh she was shoplifting
and she was like I have no idea what
you're talking about she's like here is
90 cents I think we're good to go was in
California that's for sure well look
look elisium uh I recommend watching it
for one I love the fight between Krueger
and uh Matt Damon's character in the EXO
suits it's good fun but uh he's old
movie Matt Damon's character is in line
the police are all robots and so the
robots stop and they're like what is in
the bag like and he's like do you really
need to search it they're like open the
bag what's like what's in the bag and
he's like hair products mostly it's a
joke and then they Whack Him with a
baton breaking his arm for
non-compliance throw him to the ground
and then dump out his bag and there's
nothing in it because he just he made a
joke but this is what you're going to
get with bad joke they're going to
automate police no question well there's
a there's a fire departments will be
automated police will be automated and
you will not like it there's a robot
police officer in the city right Patrol
and Subways how's that thing working out
probably terrifying you probably just
push it in front of a train and it's
there's like nothing to do not that you
should I'm not advocating for
destruction of police property in any
way but you know the thing is what is it
going to do run after you like is it
going to go up steps could it someone
who's resisting like I don't I live in
LA I have no problems they won't they
won't bother they won't
bother yeah that's crazy yeah seriously
it's like what 900 bucks so J yeah being
La I've seen the craziest stuff just
walking out of the store and then I'm
standing there like oh I guess I'm still
going to pay for this the look like an
idiot at the grocery line when someone's
walking out with like $100 in the back I
think the minimum is what under a, bucks
yeah it's under 900 it reminds me of
those studies on productivity I don't
know if you ever seen this but if you
have like an open Office concept and you
have a really high performing employee
the people seated around them will also
tend to you know generate more work be
more productive but if you have a low
performance employee they bring down
everyone around them too thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net